good day and god's blessings to all the
wonderful people of the virgin islands
the year 2021 has been a year of highs
and lows andrew foy hadn't reckoned on
the lows of 2022.
he's brought scandal and corruption to
the british virgin islands
according to charges filed in the u.s
he'd agreed ports in the british
overseas territory could store cocaine
in exchange he'd get a cut of the
profits
mr foy thought he was dealing with a
mexican drug cartel but the plan was a
sting by undercover us agents
it's not shocking to me
to see something like this but as far as
i'm concerned
it's a good thing
because it sends a strong message to
others that if you're involved in drug
trafficking corruption
your justice will sooner or later fall
on your head
court papers describe how mr foy used a
calculator to work out how many millions
he'd make in the same papers a port
official who's also been arrested said
of mr foy you see of my premier he's a
little crook sometimes he's not always
straight
the caribbean is incredibly important
transit route for the cocaine trade and
it goes across to the to the narco
states of west africa uh guinea guinea
bissau senegal they're all they're all
run by international cartels
the british virgin islands are a
tropical tax haven but there's a shady
side to the secretive goings-on here
that is please a yes or no question
i don't think that you can actually tell
me how to answer you know with due
respect
last year the uk started an inquiry into
allegations of missed governance it made
headlines when the former attorney
general jeffrey cox represented andrew
foy
publications been brought forward
following the arrests
the inquiry found appalling failings and
recommended the government be suspended
for two years with direct rule by the
governor
a difficult decision for local
politicians they've lost their powers
and probably their premiere too laura
bundock sky news